and now let's hear from the girls do you
think most girls are objective or do you
think they think they're hotter than
they are or do they underrate themselves
personally I think it depends on the
person because growing up I'm obviously
not skinny hi everyone I'm not skinny so
growing up I was never the be standard
for anyone so like all my friends were
getting chatted up by people blah blah
blah and I was just the other one you
know so like I never really thought of
myself as an attractive person like I
would never call myself anything more
than a thought but now like I didn't
really care about what anyone thinks
about me like I've grown into myself and
I've I've I'm comfortable with who I am
now that like even if I you guys call me
delusion or whatever I think I'm maybe
not 10 let's not go that far but like
definitely an egg per so like whether
you guys think I am or not yeah that's
got nothing to do with her